今回の動画では金のスイッチを手に入れるために天才小学生やネスケが
金の家に強盗しに行っちゃうよ。私どうなるのか最後まで見てね。
バンカラジオ
みんな見てて。し
みんなおはよう。
ん言うとお前も鬼にならないか。鬼になったよ。
何それ?知らないの?鬼滅だよ。見てなくてわかんないな。
鬼滅はみんな見てるよね。
そうだよ。
はい、授業始めるぞ。
あ、柱浜子郎じゃん。よぼやぼやだ。クズとして不だし。パチンコ屋があったら入りたい
[音楽]
じゃなくて死な。お前らそれ。
じゃあ心ます。
鬼滅の刃先生も見てるのか。
お母さん学校で流行ってるから鬼滅の刃みたい。は、
あんたそれNetflix
とかでお金かかるんでしょ?あんたは
5日目でも読んだ。これ何回も読んだし
巻だけじゃ話わかんないよねえ。お願い。お金ないって言ってるだ
い。ててて。あ、ほやさんだ。
鬼滅の刃の漫画とか売ってるのかな?
あ、鬼滅の刃だ。500円か。
買えないなあ。
[音楽]
何か探してるのかい?
おい、待ちなさい
。
いてい。あ、やっちゃった。盗んじゃったよ。面白。明日みんなと学校で話せるぞ。
[音楽]
おはよう。
俺の名前はハゲだ。
この頭皮練り上げられている思考の領域に近い。
鬼滅俺も読んだんだ。
うちすごい。
世界に5
台しかない銀の水どうやって手に入れたの?
僕の家お金持ちだからパパは買ってくれたんだ。
え?あの2回も守ってるじゃん。ほら
1億円する気のせ。
1億円する金のスイッチスタト。
やっべえ。めっちゃ光ってる。これね、
すっごい高いからね、めちゃめちゃ大事に
していきたいと思うけどパチン。
てパチン。
で、パチン。
あ、パン。
これなんと防水出し世界一頑丈なので取れ
ませ。
むちゃくちゃ効果なので最強の金庫に閉まっておきま
[音楽]
偽と一緒ってすご。
学校のWi-Fi使ってスイッツ2
で割りかしようよ。け
[拍手]
あ、俺も。け。
あ、それ昔のスイッチだからマリカできないね。行け行け行け行け。
あ、そっか。け
け。
ああ、お前らするぞ。
この前本屋で盗南事件があったんだが、犯人はまだ捕まっていないらしい。お前らも気をつけるように。
僕の家は貧乏で何にもないから心配なし。ボ
[音楽]
うちのお風呂1年間お湯変えてません。
やねちゃん、まこもって知ってる?
お母さんスイッチ2がさ、
また買って買ってうるさくする気スイッチなら買ってあげたでしょ。
そうだけどうちはお湯も変えられないぐらいお金なて
[拍手]
くそ。お母さんは話聞いてくれないし。友達にはまた仲間にされたよ。いいな。金のスイッチ。そうだ。盗めばいいんだ。
金の水を手に入れれば俺も学校で人気物になれる。
和室和わ室ジャパニー。
よし、これで準備万タだ。ここは
[音楽]
2金の家。今回はここから金のスイッチ
2を盗む。金庫にたどり着くには防犯
カメラやスナイパー、警備員、そして
ペットの猫が立ちかる。ただ大丈夫だって
。僕天才ですから。
玄関には監視カメラがついている。そして
偽石の兄2金がスナイパーとして狙って
いる。
[音楽]
だが鏡を使って太陽の反射で。お
お、目、目が目が
目をくらませて倒す。お、
[拍手]
大丈夫ですか?
折れてはいないと思うけど。痛い。ここなら防犯カメラがない。
[音楽]
ん?警備員が立ってるな。ここはバレないように慎重に。
ここは
見帯脅明かせ屋からはここで生売する。
あれはペットの猫丸
貴様がこれから行くのは地獄だ。
やばい。無限に落ちていく。これだ。
よくあそこを抜けただがここで死んでもらう。
うお。鼻神楽。見え部。臭い。焼けるように臭い。
[音楽]
猫は人間の20
万倍が効くんだってな。俺の匂いで失進してな。
うお。むにゃむにゃ。
[音楽]
むにゃむにゃ。むにゃむにゃ。
忙しすぎて寝てるんだ。今がチャンス。
むにゃむにゃむにゃむにゃ。
セキュリティをどかさないと。
遊びに来てるよ。
あ、マロスマ。よし、これであとは金庫を開けるだけ。かつかな音を頼りに金庫のパスワードを特置
[音楽]
2だ。
これで俺も人気者になれる。おお。関様行きましょう。ああ、頼だ。怪示だな。
[音楽]
おお、
いいか?2
金の命が欲しかったらお前ら下がれ。
許せんな。許せんだ。
黙れ。うぞ。死ぬ。死んだ。
[拍手]
ま、通報だけどな。
まずい。警察が来る前に逃げないと。
お前ら。近づくなよ。近づくなよ。
近づくな。俺以上な。
近づけな。近づけな。俺の金スイッチがスイッチ。
今日集まってもらったのは他でもございません。金のスイッチ
2俺もゲットしたんだ。
すげえ。
うろん、金のスイッチ2
で一緒に通信しようぜ。
いいよ。あ、君たちは普通のスイッチ2
だから仲間に入れないね。い
や、
伊誌の自宅に強盗が入った模様です。強盗班は現在も逃走中です。
怖いニュースなんよ。
あ、言うと、ここだけの話。あれ?俺がやったんだ。
これも2
の家から取ってきたんだよ。これで俺も人気者ってわけ。あ、
ん、それは良くないんじゃないかな。だって
2世間も困ってるし。
でもさ、俺だって流行りについていけないとみんなの仲間外れにされちゃうじゃん。
やねちゃは気にしすぎないよ。僕も貧乏で流行りにはついていけないけど、みんなに合わせてたら楽しいよ。言うとお前も鬼にならないか?
[音楽]
鬼って何のことかな?角あればいいっか。リブ鬼になったよ。
学校のWi-Fi使ってsイ2
で割り化しようよ。スイッツ
2はきっとこれないよ。いい。
[音楽]
行けイエイイエイ。キアだ。
物を盗んだら心がむズムずするからあんまり良くないよ。だって今屋ねちゃ便は楽しいん。あいたいたたた。
[音楽]
なんだか心が痛くて素直に楽しめない。俺反省するよ。もう絶対しない。ありがとう。流行りに乗れてなくても僕たちは友達なんよ。みんなで外で遊ぶんよ。
いいね。
そしたらドので遊ぶんよ。
イエー。
[音楽]
え、でも犯罪は犯罪なんよ。しっかり泥棒した罪を償うんよ。等の罪でおやりすを逮捕する。ちょ、ちょっとちょっと待って。
[拍手]
次はどんな動画が見たい